randolph seminole taylor
telfel terrell thomas tift tombs
fruitland twigs wear warren wheeler
white
those are the 43 that are done now the
big ones obviously
are the ones that take the longest of
the biggest concern potentially so
as you all heard earlier there was an
issue in fulton
where they made some errors in their
processing
and then rescan now in the rescan
we've they had 11 uh scanners
but the state supply two additional ones
and then we
supply four more to get through 17
scanners running right now
they have finished all their election
day ballots
and they are part way through their
absentee ballots now
they've done some things that i don't
think we would have said to do like
yesterday they quit at 4 45
today they're quitting at five o'clock
and their plan tomorrow is to scan from
7 a.m to 11
to get to the balance of the absentees
and then through their absentee
in-person votes they have
dekalb county is done with physical
scanning
they're dealing with one thing on
adjudication cobb county is done with
the physical scanning
gwinnett county had about 120 000
ballots left this morning
and they're 60 through them by the time
they
knock off today they plan to get the
balance of those done tomorrow morning
probably before lunch
so when they'll finish that scan those
are the big four
everybody else is somewhere in the
process of finishing up the scan
and getting ready to upload everything
to the enr and that site will likely be
live sometime tomorrow
um for the public to see now that's
for the recount moving on to the
december 1st election this is a reminder
there is an election seven counties
tomorrow um the biggest ones we'll have
seen
are the congressional five race to
replace the final month of john lewis's
term
the state senate 39 democrat special
primary to
replace nakima williams and the western
district
western district district attorney slot
in clark and oconee county
for the replacement of the d.a there so
those are the biggest ones there's a
handful of other ones that municipal
county level
but those are the big ones so those will
be operating tomorrow
now for january 5th i want to put some
more
specifics on some of the absentee
numbers i gave you all earlier on the
rollover list for
the january election it was 604 thousand
255
in total 488 thousand 238 of those were
fulfilled by the state's
vendor run back and those are all out in
the mail
and additional 116 017 were done through
fort orange and that was for
dekalb and gwinnett county they chose to
use a different vendor for that
but all the rollover ballots are out so
in total right now when you include the
rollover ballots plus new requests
and this is including those that are
pending on the online dashboard right
now
it's 947 928 requests
so that means that on top of 604 000
there's 343
673 new requests for absentees
of those 343 673
319 022 have come through the online
portal
i mean there's not a signature match
angle to this it is using the driver's
license number to identify the voter
which is the more objective way that the
secretary wants to move
in the future where we can legislatively
because signature match is a very
subjective thing to do
let's see those are the main points of
where we stand on this right now
um we continue to run the investigations
we've discussed this morning
and hopefully this will be a short one
so i'll take whatever questions you got
justin bieber who got anybody
walking up
and they are also publicly available to
be viewed and we are hopeful that
republicans and democrats will send
themselves to do that because
under the state law it does say all
parts of the ballot process
are available for public review emma
[Music]
as i know that there was i haven't able
to track this down it's my understanding
that our elections director did receive
one phone call from one county director
and he thinks he has his own business
with a phone call he doesn't have an
email to
go back and look to or one person
requested to go and see it may have done
it for a day or two
i know that the this office did inform
the parties that they could do this and
there was some confusion around
if there had to be a new oeb for that
and the contention of this office was no
there didn't need to be one because
it's already in the law that the entire
process is open for public duty
one person as i understand it and i i
can't figure
who specifically is because the phone
call from you know a month and a half
two months ago yes ma'am
okay um so it sounded like you're a
little bit concerned about fulton county
possibly finishing in time for the
deadline what do you have to say about
kind of the progress and
the expectation to meet that deadline
the expectation is
given the last sets of ballots they have
to do they are the absentee person which
are the
uh eight and a half by eleven bar coded
ones they should be able to move faster
on that than they did today because
today they're doing the 18 inch hand
mark ones
so we anticipate they can usually get
300 000 or so done in a day like that so
if they're gonna be there all day they
should be able to do it
again that's not the way that i
personally would have managed through
that
prospect and kind of pushing it towards
the end i'd rather have more time to
deal with it might come up because you
know it's 20 20 and it's fulton county
but in general i think we're still on a
good path to have every county including
fulton county meet our deadline of
midnight homelessness
yes
um they they have to be done by the
counties to begin with so that
that's set in the law and that's what we
will continue to say
if there is a lawsuit that comes forward
or an election challenge that a judge
says has to be said in toronto that's up
to that judge
sure hello
i guess let's cross that bridge we come
to that i mean we'll have to deal with
it
we have sometimes kind of baked in the
cake
but the intention is not the intention
of the rule is
this recount will now become the new
certified election results so if there's
anything different
a county would have to come back in and
recertified in the state if any county
recertifies the states have to recertify
as well so we need to have that
time kind of baked in the cake by friday
to get done so that's why what shows the
wednesday night deadline
on the justice case something that might
happen but our intention is to hold
everybody speak to the fire and make
that
that deadline like we did in the handgun
we can't we got on the handout we can
get it on this one
yes
there'll be a separate enr page that'll
go up we'll say recount results i just
saw the banner for it about an hour ago
would look very similar but it will just
be the presidential race on that
[Music]
based on what
the 43 we've seen so far there's either
spot on or not anything significant
so that that's those are the 43 we know
about so far that we've seen their
initial report
it's only the presidential race the psc
race was requested at the wrong time
using the statute they were trying to do
and they needed to outline the
irregularities if
if they've done it before certification
post certification the only
uh recount request can be done in the
half percent being within the second
place finish or the third place finisher
going to a runoff
just make sure i understood this
correctly we were talking about the
absentee ballot request
you have more than 300 000 new requests
people who did not request
for the general election is that right
no what this is these are
new requests as compared to the rollover
requests because remember for each
subsequent election that the elector
would have to choose to make that
choice so in this case
again new requests not part of the
rollover list for 343
673 and of those 319 022 came through
the absentee ballot portal
so there's not a signature issue on the
front end of that that's going to be
identified through the unique identifier
of the driver's license
i don't know the answer to that honestly
but we we
moved pretty fast on that front if we
did that but no we have to be thorough
in these investigations and most
investigations will involve having to
do direct interviews with people to
really track down the truth behind them
all right well that's it we'll see you
all later this week
and hopefully we'll have the results in
for the
recount and we move on on a successful
lesson tomorrow thanks have a great day
okay real quick